[Music]
the S Louis chess club is celebrating
its 15th year anniversary tell me a
little bit about its impact in the
United States and do you have any
favorite
moments uh yes certainly so St Louis
chess club has become our home for
professional chess players all the
biggest events are held here and um it
certainly is my second home I have a lot
of random memories uh I think one of the
biggest ones was uh finishing US
championships last year I was surrounded
by a lot of friends and family and it
was just like really special um really
special moment it definitely has brought
the rise of American chess I remember my
first championship here in
2014 and that's probably one of my most
memorable memories especially my first
game here and I just love coming back to
St Louis and playing so they really did
a great job with American chess I don't
have a lot of experience here but uh I
heard a lot of good things about St
Louis chess club the impact that the St
Louis chess club had on like kids
education and I know that a lot of like
Grand Masters come here like every month
yeah the St Louis chess club has had a
huge impact on chess in the US I
remember when I was playing in the US
Championship prior to when it moved to
the St Louis chess club and um I do
appreciate that the US Championship was
still being held but it wasn't as
prestigious as it is now the price fund
was lower we're playing two rounds a day
so I feel like it has elevated chess to
a new level especially women's chess uh
I'm very happy to come to St Louis every
year and even a couple times in a year
yes American chess was completely
different I moved to United States and
2002 and there's I cannot even compare
like chess situation in now and back in
those years and main reason why I'm
still playing chess at St Louis because
I'm the oldest participant already for
many years and it's keep me motivated
and it's
really it's really nice that we have
this opportunity to play us championship
at such a nice place and that we have so
many good tournament I think that the
impact it has is huge on us chess for
people both who are watching the games
um of Chess and the players who are up
and coming um I think the same that
chess clubs provides young players with
a lot of great opportunities and uh I'm
really happy that is the 15th
anniversary um and I hope that uh the St
Louis J will continue to have these
amazing tournaments well U my favorite
memory about it is when I came to 2021
for the US Champs how they CH with me
and then the whole experience is
wonderful St Louis chess club really did
a great job in promoting chess in
general in the US but especially for
women's chess you know I grew up playing
in the US Championship you know my first
time I was like 13 now I'm 21 so um I
think it's done a lot especially for
girls chess because it's been you know
something I returned to multiple times
every year for like the last 8 years so
yeah like I don't know where I would be
in chess or like in general if it wasn't
for a s l chess love the club has done
so much for chess here in America and
it's been such a long time I don't
remember when like I can't remember a
time like before St Louis um here you
know I remember like growing up watching
all the broadcast on like YouTube
following along us Champs and stuff and
it was always like the highlight of my
my day back when I was a kid yeah well
the St Louis chess club has had has had
such an amazing impact on American chess
I mean it seems like it just got better
and better every year gave so many
opportunities to players um and
certainly it's like it's a motivating
thing for me as a chess player like the
level the number of high quality events
that we're having here you know kind of
um giv gives you a chance to really stay
as a professional player in terms of
memories here I mean in a way they all
fade into each other right cuz you just
come here like year after year numerous
times I mean it feels like home for me
um any place that I look at I'll think
oh yeah I remember I was really sad
after this game and I went to sit in
that place in Forest Park you know so I
have memories like that but I'll tell
you something funny like recently um
Tony Rich the director of the club he he
was talking about the memories that he
had and he's like I remember how at the
very beginning I saw Arena Crush in her
cool leather jacket and I was like yeah
why don't I wear that anymore so I'm
back to wearing the leather
[Music]
jackets